la parole à monsieur philippe marini
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président du sénat cette
question s'adresse à monsieur pierre
moscovici
monsieur le ministre on nous a fait des
annonces cette semaine donc beaucoup mes
chers collègues monsieur le président
sincèrement il serait préférable que
l'on puisse s'exprimer
pour deux minutes et demie correctement
et avec un minimum d coûte
monsieur le sénateur vous avez deux
minutes trente je vous en prie allez-y
monsieur le ministre
des annonces ont été faites beaucoup
d'entre nous pensent qu'il s'agit d'une
simple diversion par rapport à une
situation très grave que le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à gérer
je voudrais dire que s'agissant de
lutter contre les excès des paradis
fiscaux
les annonces qui ont été faites sont
excellentes dans leur principe mais
qu'il faut aussi savoir utiliser les
outils qui existent déjà
or à la suite de la crise financière
des réunions du g20 un raison de
conventions internationales s'est
perfectionnée en particulier avec la
suisse ceux ci donnant lieu à la
signature d'un avenant qui a été
postérieurement en février 2010 est
tendue par un échange de lettres entre
les directeurs des administrations
fiscales suisses et françaises
cet échange de lettres vous aurait
permis
monsieur le ministre d'interroger
beaucoup plus largement que vous ne
l'avez fait l'administration fiscale
suisse pour savoir si oui ou non un
certain docteur cahuzac détenait bien
directement ou indirectement des comptes
en suisse
monsieur le ministre pourquoi avez vous
limitez votre question
de manière étroite à la seule banque ubs
en second lieu et alors qu'il était de
notoriété publique
monsieur le ministre que d'éventuels
comptes en suisse avait pu être déplacés
vers singapour
pourquoi n'at-on pas utiliser la
convention franco singapourienne qui
remonte à la même époque et qui
permettait de s'assurer auprès de cet
état qu'il y avait ou qu'il n'y avait
pas de compte
monsieur le ministre vous avez bien
voulu me répondre par écrit les réponses
qui ont été faites ne me semble pas
épuisé le sujet d'autant que ces
réponses me paraissent aujourd'hui être
éclairée par de nouveaux bruits de
nouvelles rumeurs de nouvelles
indications parues dans la presse qui
probablement sinon bleus de cet apn ce
n'en est qu'à ses débuts
merci la parole à pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président marini mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai lu évidemment j'ai entendu toutes
les questions mais aussi tous les
raccourcis toutes les simplifications
sur ce qu'on a l affaire cahuzac
je répète ici qu'il s'agit de la faute
du mensonge d'un homme pas d'une
responsabilité collective et prenez
garde à ne pas tomber dans ce type de
dérives
je vois ce matin de nouvelles
allégations dans un hebdomadaire à
droite très à droite très très à droite
je veux parler de valeurs actuelles
allégation qui vous conduiront cet après
midi vous êtes le bienvenu à venir au
ministère des finances pour vérifier le
quoi il s'agit mais je veux dire ici
avec la plus grande force la plus grande
fermeté que ces allégations sont
mensongères que je les dément que les
mensonges les combats et que je me
réserve d'eau des suites de tout cela
devant la justice pour le reste je veux
m'en tenir aux faits puisque dans vos
qualités vous m'avez interrogé et c'est
légitime
monsieur le président la commission des
finances c'est facile de réécrire
l'histoire
posteriori il y avait bien ici ou là des
analyses mais une seule mise en cause
existait c'était sale de mediapart qui
disait que jérôme cahuzac aurait possédé
début 2010 un compte à la banque ubs en
suisse
ensuite transféré à singapour c'est
cette information là et c'est la seule
que l'administration fiscale a cherché à
vérifier à travers une convention
d'entraidé avec la suisse j'ai déjà
répondu sur le champ de notre demande
d'entre elles nous avons interrogé sur
la banque ubs car nous n'avions pas
d'éléments à cette date qui permettait
de viser d'autres établissements
financiers et sur ce point
vous évoquez un avenant mais cet avenant
contrairement à ce que vous dites il est
plus restrictif que la convention sur ce
point là il ne permettait pas d'évoquer
des circonstances ou des conditions
exceptionnelles nous avons demandé aux
autorités suisses
et personne ne l'avait fait avant nous
personne aucun gouvernement de remonter
loin dans le temps jusqu'en 2006 date de
la prescription fiscale
nous avons demandé pour ce qui
concernait non seulement monsieur camus
zac mais des ayants droit ça pouvait
être des intermédiaires nous avons
demandé aussi s'il y avait eu transfert
et sur tous ces points je dis bien tous
ces points la réponse des autorités
suisses elle est claire nette précise
négative alors je dis qu ensuite tout a
été transmis à qui de droit
d'abord la police judiciaire puisqu'il
est une enquête ensuite quand vous
l'avez demandé à vous même dans votre
qualité de président de la commission
des finances
alors pour terminer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
permettez moi de m'adresser à vous un
peu personnellement dans cette affaire
l'administration fiscale a fait tout ce
qu'elle pouvait elle a fait tout ce
qu'elle devait dans le respect du droit
et c'est fondamental
elle était comme toujours remarquable
honnête vigoureuse rigoureuse et prenons
garde a ici le transformer la faute d'un
homme en attaque contre un gouvernement
qu au cra ministres intègres à ne pas
salir cette administration qui est une
des plus capable du monde une des plus
compétentes que je suis fier aujourd'hui
de diriger avec bernard cazeneuve
ces pionniers monsieur le président si
vous le voulez vous savez ce phoque le
disais il n'est pas de choses plus
blessante cas reproches injustes mais
quand on a rien à se reprocher on
affronte les reproches avec fermeté
c'est ce que je fais merci